hey everyone welcome back to my round
six recap from Buell in this game I
played Jonathan Monte Verde rated 2074.
and coming into this game I have a
little bit more time to prepare than
usual because yesterday was a rest day I
did play The Blitz tournament yesterday
stay tuned for some fun footage of that
but I basically had a day and a half to
research my opponent and decide which
opening to go for and I decided to play
a completely new line that I've never
played before starting with Knight F3 D5
and then E3
for those that have been watching my
recaps closely you'll maybe remember
that I played B3 in round two but E3 is
a very new move for me and if we look at
this position in the Masters database E3
is the fourth most popular move
um but what I did to learn this opening
was I actually plugged in
hikaru's chess.com games into a site
called openingtree.com
and it loaded in over 24 000 of hikaru's
games uh mainly Blitz and bullets but um
I knew that Hikaru likes to play this
line so what I did was I basically just
went through his opening repertoire
starting with this position and for a
few hours before the game I just looked
at the different possibilities black can
play and what Hikaru does in response so
my game plan coming into this game was
basically just to follow hikaru's
opening repertoire within the system and
get my opponent into a position that
maybe he would be a little less
comfortable with
so going back to leechas uh I should
note the point of e3 is to avoid certain
lines back can usually play against
already for one lines that involve
Bishop F5 and Bishop G4 are a bit less
attractive because white has a quick C4
and queen B3 which I was ready to play
on top of this if we go back and look at
the move C4 I check my opponent schemes
and he likes to play D4 in this position
so E3 is essentially a proprietory move
making it so C4 can be played and then
it's a lot more difficult for black to
actually get in the move d4
so um I played E3 and my opponent took
his first think of the game on on just
the second move and he played Knight F6
I quickly played C4 he played E6 and I
played Knight to C3 and for the most
part I knew that this is what Hikaru
likes to do basically delaying D4 and
after Bishop to E7 I play Pawn to B3
now I will say that before the game I
was looking more at Bishop D6 lines but
I played this position a lot from the
box side and it's actually a line that I
haven't been super comfortable with over
the years so it's nice playing the other
side of the line and um I already knew
some some ideas from the white side just
based on my experience from playing this
position as black
so going forward after castling Bishop
B2 V6 I take on D5
opponent takes back and in this position
I was debating between two different
moves we do see there's a game Hikaru
against topolov that Caro played D4 in
this game but I was debating between uh
either playing Pawn D4 which I was aware
that Hikaru usually goes for but there's
another kind of cool trendy move that's
been popping up recently is this move
Pawn to G3 and it's only been played a
few times in this specific position but
the idea would be to play Bishop G2
castle and then have the double fintado
with just long-term pressure in the
center
so I was very tempted to play G3 but I
figured that I would stick with the more
mainstream move and I played D4 and in
this position my opponent surprised me a
little bit I was either expecting Bishop
to B7 or Bishop F5 but he started with
the move Pawn to C6 which is pretty rare
and um at this point I'm officially out
of any sort of opening preparation but
it's still a pretty solid position for
whites and it's just a matter of
completing development
so let me hide the notation to avoid
spoilers
and going forward from here I played
Bishop to D3
and my opponent played Bishop A6 which
was maybe uh maybe explains the reason
why he played C6 was to wait for me to
play Bishop D3 and then offer the trade
of Bishops and now I'm in a situation
where I don't really want to trade my
lights for a bishop because it's a great
piece with this Pawn structure but if I
play Bishop C2 then this bishop actually
is very strong preventing light from
casting so I was mainly debating here
between taking on A6 or just leaving the
tension between the Bishops and I chose
to leave the tension with the move 95
and this does thread to take advantage
of the fact that this Knight is
overworked so I'm threatening to take on
A6 and then take on C6 if lack's not
careful but he took on D3 first I take
back with queen and it is a little bit
awkward for lock in this position
because a knight on B8 is tied down to
defending the C6 Pawn so he played the
move Knight F to D7 which does look
passive but it's a move that I was
expecting I think it's the best approach
for Bach to try and get rid of this
knight from E5
so here I castle and then he takes and I
take and the structure transforms a
little bit I now have this extended Pawn
on E5 uh double e pawns but I figured
that the E5 Pawn isn't super weak
because in most cases it's supported by
the bishop in other cases I can play F4
or queen F5 to support it further so I
was still feeling pretty good here and
then he plays Knight to D7 attacking the
pawn I played 92 unleashing the bishop
to defend the pawn and then he plays
Pawn F6 and I think this is a first like
real critical moment for me in the game
uh because I have a lot of options here
I can take on F6 I was considering
playing E6 which would I think walk into
a line like Knight C5 and then Queen F5
But ultimately I chose to play the move
Knight to F4 exploiting the fact that E6
square is now undefended and I'm
threatening to Fork the queen and The
Rook now when I played this move I
actually overlooked my opponent's
response what I was expecting was Knight
takes E5 and I was actually expecting
him to sacrifice exchange after which I
would take take go in
um I thought maybe he would play E4 and
then let's say queen not Queen C3 maybe
Queen E2 Queen D7 takes takes and I
spent a lot of time
exploring this position in my
calculations and trying to gauge whether
black is okay or if white can play for
win I figured white should be having
very good winning chances here
um having The Rook for Bishop and pawn
but we didn't go into this because my
opponent played what I think is the best
approach is to take on E5 at the pawn
and after I played 96 I completely
forgot that my opponent hasn't moved
Knight C5 and not actually winning the
exchange given that my queen is attacked
and the Knights attacked and here if I
want to take on d8 then we trade Queens
but I think the sign is good for black
because if I take on C6 there's Bishop
D6 and I'm not winning E5 and my knight
is a bit misplaced my Bishop's attacked
so rather than going for this
going back a few moves after Knight C5 I
just trade Knights and after he takes I
take on E5
so a lot of liquidation a lot of Trades
and it's still equal material but I was
still feeling comfortable just because I
have these two half open files the C D
files and it just seems like a very easy
position for white to play bring the
Rooks in and pressure the pawns which
could very easily be targets
and here I was expecting my opponent to
play Bishop D6 to offer the traded
Bishops but he played the move Bishop to
E7 which does look a little bit passive
at first
and the first thing that came to mind
was the fact that I have Queen C3
hitting G7 and C6
but I ended up just quickly rejecting
this move because I thought Bishop F6 is
a useful way for Bach to defend because
my queen would be tied down and if here
here if I take on F6 black can take back
and defend the C6
but after the game I had a quick call
with Jonathan trance who was doing
commentary for my twitch Channel and he
told me that I had a missed opportunity
here a queen C3 is actually very strong
for white and what I missed is after
Bishop F6 this is white to move and
white has actually a pretty simple
continuation I can just take on C6 a
loud Bishop takes E5 and then win the
bishop back and just be up a pawn so
this was a pretty unfortunate missed
opportunity because I think if I found
Queen Z3 black would have been under
major pressure now there are some kind
of confusing lines here uh the best move
for a buck is to play C5 and I can't
actually take on G7 because there's this
move d4 which would win the bishop but
after a move like Rook to D1 uh White is
in full control and the d-pawn is
actually a very big Target now I videos
of Rook D3 and Rook fd1 I think it's
very likely that white will be winning
upon uh there is even triple battery
potential to just triple stack on the D
file
so unfortunately we didn't go into that
and instead of Queen C3 I started with
Rook C1 and it still seems like White's
supplying a lot of pressure but my
opponent played very solidly to just
cover all the bases starting with Bishop
Essex
and I avoid the trade of Bishops he
defends a c Pawn I bring my Rook to D1
and then he plays Bishop to H4 and I
have to be careful here that I don't
allow the position to simplify too much
and I really wanted to keep Bishops on
the board but if I avoid the bishop
trade then there could be some issues
with F2
so I decided here to play the move Rook
C2 uh basically just preparing either
Rook 2 C1 to double on the C file or
maybe even Rook D2 and eventually E4 so
I'm keeping the options open which file
to double up on and here my opponent
took on G3 I take back and he plays
Queen to F6 so putting some pressure on
F2 my C Rook is currently tied down to
defending
I play Queen to Asics hitting the pawn
on A7 and here I thought that it's very
easy for black to blunder because not
only am I attacking the a pawn I'm also
attacking the D5 Pawn given that now the
C Pawn is pinned to The Rook on C8 Queen
is an additional attacker so if lock is
not careful and plays a move like Queen
E7 then I can happily take on D5 and go
up a pawn
but my opponent was careful here he
played the move Queen F7 which just
keeps everything defended
I played Queen to D3 so I didn't really
make any progress with Queen A6 and I
decided my queen is better off in the
center and then he plays Rook 2 d8 uh
taking advantage of the fact that I
can't take on C6 because my Rook is
still tie down to defending F2
and here it seems pretty clear that he's
preparing to play Ponzi five and perhaps
eventually expand in the center with
Pawn D4 where the Rook would be
supporting the um the d-pawn
so I wanted to still keep the pressure
and here I decided to play Pawn E4 uh
taking advantage of the fact that the
d-pawn is pinned and black can't take
because I just take take take and I'm
winning back the queen and I'll be up a
rook in the end so after E4 my opponent
played Queen F6 which just keeps all the
tension defending C6
I play Rook D2 so tripling up on the D
file and again there's some calculations
my opponent can't take on e4 because I
take take take and even though I'm not
forcing queen f8 I'm still winning the
queen after King F7 Rook D7 the king is
forced to one of these squares and then
Rook D6 is coming next
so yeah there's still a lot of pressure
on the D file and rather than trying to
relieve any tension my opponent
basically just play The Waiting move
Pawn H6 and put the ball back in my
courts and it wasn't entirely clear how
I can best make progress here so I did
take a pretty long think and ultimately
decided on the Move Queen to D4
essentially offering the queen trade
because if takes and takes then I think
white is winning a pawn given that D5
just doesn't have enough Defenders
so I'm really trying to keep the
pressure also exploit my opponent's time
situation but he kept resisting he
played the move Queen to G5 and again I
took another long think and I decided to
take on D5
and I spent a long time casually the
lines after Rook takes D5 and queen C4
pinning and just putting pressure on the
queen side and I thought black is
actually doing okay here after a move
like Rook d8 I was trying to make sense
of this in my calculations for example
takes and takes and I don't actually
have time to take on C6 because my Rooks
attacked if I take here I was trying to
calculate like this King Pawn ending but
I don't think white has any chances to
win this
but we didn't go into any of this
because rather than taking with a rook
my opponent took with a c pawn and I
think this is a misjudgment maybe he was
scared of lines with Queen C4 but after
he takes with the pawn
now I have a very clear weakness to try
and exploit and my game plan from here
was to just put as much pressure on my
opponent as possible and to try
gradually improving my queen and my
Rooks as well and the move I started
with here is Queen to A4 eyeing the
undefended A7 pawn my opponent defended
with Rook F7 and then I play Queen C6 so
having now three attackers against the
d-pawn but after Rook to D7 my opponent
has three Defenders and I'm not winning
the pawn and if I'm not careful here
then maybe black is ready to push and I
did not want to allow D4 so for that
reason I play Rook D4
and we get a position where black is a
bit stuck basically just has to wait
so we see Rook D6 I draw back with the
queen king and queen to D3 so I'm
rerouting the queen to a more Central
Square
and after he played the move Rook to D7
I finally had a clear plan in the
position last few moves were just kind
of moving around poking and prodding but
in this position I play the move Rook to
E1
I understood the fact that my Rook
doesn't really have a purpose on D1 when
the D5 Pawn is defended and the e-file
is fully open but the plan in this
position is actually to make use of this
E5 square and what I wanted to do with
this move is play F4 and rookie 5. and I
thought if I could establish such a
setup with the pawn defending the pawn
defending the Rook constantly attacking
the D5 pawn and also
chasing the queen away from G5 I thought
this would be a really nice way to just
try and dominate the position on top of
that I wanted to have a square for The
Rook that controls H5 Square so my king
could come to H2 and not have to worry
about getting checked given that all
these squares would be in my control so
going forward from here we're gonna see
how this plays out after Rook C8 I do
play F4 he plays Queen H5 and I play
rookie five and this feels like
significant progress because I'm hitting
the queen on H5 also hitting the pawn
and I wasn't so worried here about Rook
C1 because I was just gonna play King F2
and if Queen H1 it looks like I might be
in trouble but I'm just mating in one so
black had to be very very careful here
he played the move Queen F7 and then I
take on D5 so this was a big
accomplishment to win Black's biggest
weakness and after takes takes it's
still takes a lot of work to win such a
position even though I'm up a pawn I
don't have any past pawns and my three
on two majority on the king side of
course it's nice but if I want to make
progress by pushing my pawns I could
potentially weaken my king so here there
is a little bit of moving around after
Rook Yates the king H2 rookie one Queen
D2 rookie seven and here I figured that
everything is under control and I might
as well make some improvements on the
queen side and I play B4 gaining a
little bit of space I figured the idea
is to play A4 and either eventually B5
or maybe even A5 and A6 and just try and
optimize my queen side pawns as much as
possible
so he kept waiting and plays rookie
eights I play A4 and then he plays a
move Rook E2 so perhaps trying to force
some simplification and I didn't want to
trade Rooks because I thought such an
end game would be even more difficult to
win for whites so I um I avoid the trade
I centralize my queen queen D4 he plays
Queen G6 and then I play Rook d8 and
after King H7 I realized in this
position that white is very very close
to winning and when I played my next
move I thought that I'm on the verge of
winning but I didn't see the the clear
win just yet but I started with the move
Queen to D5
which not only Trends Checkmate in one
but it also prevents any sort of counter
play with Queen H5 so I'm finding very
nice harmony with the queen in The Rook
and at this point I was expecting the
move Rook E8 but my opponent surprised
me with the move Rook E6 which at first
it looks like it walks into a fork I
should note F5 doesn't quite work
because there's Queen H5 check and then
after this actually lights getting mated
here rookie one uh and this is mate so
F5 would be a terrible terrible blunder
but rather than playing a five I played
the move Rook f8
and after I played this move I thought
that black is really close to being in
zugzvan because the Rook is basically
pinned to the G8 square and the queen is
very short on squares as well and it's
tied down to the Rook so there's really
not too many moves that I can consider
in this position in a move like H5 then
allows Pawn F5 because there's no more
Queen H5 check so this would be winning
for white
so after Rook f8 as my point was
thinking I was expecting him to play the
move Queen G4 and he did and this is a
one move I couldn't quite see a clear
win and I ended up taking a lot of time
in this position to calculate and what
ended up happening in the game was
exactly according to my calculations
because in this position there is
actually a relatively forcing line
and I guess for anyone watching that
wants to treat this physician as an
exercise feel free to pause the video
and try and find not only the next move
for white but the sequence for white
that will hopefully lead to a win
and I started with Queen to D3 uh
attacking the king opponent blocks with
Rook G6
and then I have the move Pawn to F5
and I think at this point black is in
big big trouble because a rook is
attacked and if the Rook moves anywhere
else other than F6 for example Rook G5
F6 check G6 and this is force mate for
white after Rook F7 King h8 is Queen d8
mate and King G7 I have check and mate
so we got to the position after F5 my
point plays rogat6 and after takes takes
from a distance it may seem like this
ending can still be very difficult for
white to win but when I looked further I
noticed that there's a very nice series
of checks that allows white to win the
game quite easily and rather than
showing the moves I just want to show
the the arrows in my calculation because
there's a funny line that involves a lot
of zigzagging but the calculation was
check here check basically the king is
stuck within these squares because of my
very strong F5 Pawn basically I would
keep checking pick up the a pawn with
check and then zigzag my way back and
eventually get to a situation where I
can have Queen G6 forcing a queen trade
and then have the two on one on the
queen side and then easily win and
basically everything played out
recordings plan after Queen D7 he played
King G8 and at first I was gonna play
Queen C8 and start zigzagging but I
realized it's more efficient to play
Queen D5 and after King G7 check and now
the zigzagging begins Queen eight and I
take the pawn with check and then here
we're gonna see the zigzag to force the
queen trade izig and then I zag and then
zig zag zig
and my opponent actually resigns before
I could do the final zag but um it was a
very nice kind of study like finish
given that it required a lot of Queen
moves a lot of Queen checks to finish
things off
but I think it was a very instructive
positional game uh very very strategic
and goes to show that even one weakness
in the middle game this isolated Queen's
Pawn for black on D5
it can sometimes be enough to end up
losing the game from the lock side and
when you're white it can sometimes be
enough to play for a win and I think I
was fortunate to convert I think maybe
my opponent didn't put up the best
resistance later on in the end game but
uh a win is a win I do want to thank
Hikaru for inspiring my opening choice
in this game with Knight F3 and E3
always nice to add a new weapon to my
repertoire
and um yeah I'm pretty tired now I
haven't had dinner yet
so I think I'm gonna end it here thanks
everyone for watching I do appreciate
those who make it until the very end of
the video so do stay tuned for more
chess I'm currently three and a half out
of six back on a plus one score round
seven is starting in
18 hours from now
so look forward to seeing you in the
next recap
and adios